in our morning rounds new research on
drugs that lower cholesterol 56 million
Americans fall under the guidelines to
take a statin to reduce cholesterol but
a new study says only about half of them
take it many start the medication but
abandon it within two years the study
highlights the dangers of ending stand
therapy including heart attacks and
death our dr. taryn Rula is a
cardiologist at Norwell health tara good
morning good morning Nora
so these statins have been around for
three decades right what are the
benefits well there are a lot of
benefits this is one of the best studied
classes of drugs in terms of high
quality trials over about 30 years and
what they have shown is that they reduce
cardiovascular mortality or death and
cardiovascular events like heart attack
and stroke we have come from an era
where we basically watched people in the
1950s and 60s in the ICU and told them
there's nothing we can do for your heart
attack but give you pain medicine and
waited for them to come back to an era
where we can prevent heart disease and
stroke so why do seventy-five percent of
people stop these drugs after two years
why is there so much controversy because
we think we're getting better well one
of the one of the issues is yes but the
other issue is that people feel well
right so we're not giving them a drug
that's making them feel better so a lot
of people think I feel fine why do I
have to take something that's one issue
one issue is concern over side-effects
20% of people will have some sort of
side effects to statins but they're
usually reversible and we need to do a
better job at explaining to people the
benefits of statins the science behind
stats so what are the benefits and what
are the written and what are the
negative effects well what this research
really looked at is is it a big deal if
I stop my statin after I have an adverse
event and it would say the answer to
that would be yes so they looked at
about 28,000 patients who had a presumed
adverse reaction
30% stopped their statin those who
continued over the next four years to
take their statin had a 10 to 20 percent
lower rate of cardiovascular events and
death that's a big deal that tells us we
need to be reach Allen geing our
patients restarting them on the
medication if they stopped and
explaining to them why they need to take
it well I remember the doctor saying to
me that once you start this you have to
always use it and that's a little
daunting when you hear that it is and it
I think we need to do a better job again
at examining how important it is how
important it is but one of the
shoes that was raised in an editorial
that accompany this paper is that the
Internet and social media have done a
disservice in terms of spreading
pseudoscience anti science and that
people end up either denying the
benefits of statins and saying well
there's really cholesterol doesn't cause
heart disease or having so much fear
around statins that they're afraid to
take it or wanting to try all-natural
diets and supplements that really have
not been proven to work
so again Kent can your diet change your
diet is definitely part of the equation
nobody is saying it's not but it can
only lower LDL by about 8 to 10 percent
men you need medication well you have
sounded the word spread the word thank
you very much it sounded the alarm